the Joe Rogan experience I enjoyed your
I enjoyed that game-changers with Chris
crecer and it's it's a little bit like
listening to a Protestant and a Catholic
argue over the min you should have had a
worship God like they both believe in
God like or like a Sunni and a Shia
it was it was very interesting in that
sense like how human beings get steeped
in in too much information and then
we'll start parsing out stuff that's not
that helpful - well it's a long
conversation the conversation about
health is very long and unfortunately
when Chris was talking about the game
changers he got several things wrong
particularly the big ones were the
amount of protein that you can get in
peanut butter the amount of protein
that's in bread and whether or not that
is equal to three ounces of ground meat
right and what Wilkes are showing is
that it is and he made his point very
well and that made Chris his argument
not look very good right and then there
was the other problem whereas Chris
Crestor sort of personally defined what
he defines as low car versus medium car
versus high carb and wasn't making a
distinction that this is not the
consensus amongst nutritionists what
they consider low carb medium car part
James accused him of that Chris denied
it and then James pulled out all of
these different articles that show that
he has a different version of what he
calls the low carb meat of carb or high
carb the problem with all this is he's
just making Chris look bad and he's not
necessarily proving that a vegetarian or
vegan diet is better for you but he is
rightly pointing out that he was wrongly
criticized yes so I guess first I was
very impressed
James ability to come prepared here I do
believe he spent three thousand hours
I'm in an hour a thousand hours I
believe that yeah I believe that now he
knows his [ __ ] after talking to him
about this in the way he handled it how
but I kept going back to what Chris was
saying which was hey hey I believe in
plants I eat mostly plants a little
animal products some animal products is
gonna it's gonna get is just an easier
way to get b1 yes that's the problem
it's not gonna kill you that's the
problem
doing a documentary and then that's a
problem with someone criticizing the
documentary you know it's like but but
the documentary he's got enough stuff
that he can say you were inaccurate with
with the criticism so that then we get
lost in the argument like is meat bad
for you is it like that's the main it's
not know that's there but the way
they're conflating it with people who
were advertising for cigarettes and
doctors advertising for cigarettes back
in the day and saying that cigarettes
are fine but these are the same people
that are doing this like no the problem
is everyone was aware for a long time
that cigarettes are not healthy right
this is not the case with me no these
studies that where you connect people
with all these diseases with meat they
connect their diet as a whole they could
be eating cheeseburgers and bread like
soda and lifestyle and drinking and
smoking but they also eat meat versus
people who don't eat meat well if
someone is going to be conscientious and
think about even if they're incorrect
and they just assume that the science
says the eating meat is bad for you you
start eating more fish or more chicken
or more vegetables you clean up your
diet
I bet just statistically those people
have less drinking that statistically
they have less it cigarette smoking
they're probably healthier on the whole
because they're making choices that even
if it's incorrect they think are good
for you like not eating meat or as much
meat but as a non nutritionist there's
no [ __ ]
yeah when I watched game-changers I have
to say that it did seem like the
narrative the story of the movie was
that being a vegan is better for you for
all these reasons all these scientific
reasons then eating any meat that's
that's what I me it was a vegan film the
honeymoons over probably disagree with
that for me just as a viewer the
argument was being made that being a
vegan that from what I from just what I
got right the retros what was meant I
got the being of vegans better for you
it keeps your dick hard
you won't die of cancer and you'll have
less inflammation more and those things
are more endurance all of which seemed
you know I talked to Lane Norton about
this
for a while he had written this thing I
don't think he had a video you could
watch his video on game changes debunked
we broke down basically every single
claim that they made that was incorrect
okay scientifically as a PhD scientist I
mean he absolutely understands the the
the what what's really going on when it
comes to nutritional science and I would
just said at the end of the day this is
a debate about can you eat some meat in
there but here's the problem because of
cursors criticism of the film he was in
every right he had every right to defend
I respect criticism respect you and he
did it right yeah the problem was we
didn't get any closer at the end there
was there was some confusion that was
about whether or not it is healthy or
not healthy to eat meat
he was citing some studies and crecer
was saying those studies aren't valid
because of this and that and that's
where we would have been if we had a guy
like Lane Norton in here would have
helped a lot we could have someone
actually explain but you could also have
a guy who comes in and goes hey guys
here's the thing man
let's just look at cultures that live a
long time and have vibrant you know
lives and good lives some of it is like
I'd like to look at the Blue Zones who
eat meat and they have a lot of times
they eat some form of dairy and they
drink they have good communities they
don't retire there's a lot more to
longevity and health and living a good
life than being a purist for sure
whether or not it's in this direction or
that direction I think it's all in
regard it's the result of a real
conversation that we really need to have
because overpopulation is real so the
conversation is really ultimately what
is sustainable you know and it's not
what is sustainable right now for your
lifespan it's like what is sustainable
for the future and should we engineer
for a better tomorrow because there are
in the are though we sort of are we're
not though people are acting as
individuals there's not really a whole
lot of engineering in terms of slowing
down the rate of childbirth or trying to
prevent people from having too many kids
trying to prevent overpopulation
whatever but there are a lot of cultures
I mean a lot of countries and societies
are at zero populations something yes
but the thing the thing is there's
plenty of people that live below the
poverty line in terms of like what are
in the poverty line is and what you're
seeing in a lot of these more
industrialized nations is as people
start developing careers and men and
women get careers you have less
childbirth like you seen that in Japan
Japan has apparently an issue with a
lack of childbirth not as many as they
should it's not sustainable
[Applause]